hey welcome in this session we're going
to be talking about applying kubernetes
app development best practices we're
going to talk about what are the best
practices and then we're going to give a
demo on how we use google cloud dev
tools to implement them
first we'd like to introduce ourselves
i'm kelsea crapane i'm a developer
relations engineer at google and i'm
abby carey a developer advocate for
google cloud's developer experiences
so as with any type of development
following best practices when working
with kubernetes can save you time and
unnecessary frustration
you may have to write lots of yaml
configuration files so unless you're a
yaml expert you'll want to have
authoring support so that you don't have
to constantly look up what property
takes what fields or memorize the basic
components of a service
for local kubernetes development you
don't need to replicate your production
cluster but it's important to have a
cluster for local dev that's configured
in a way that ensures that what you're
building will be compatible with the
production cluster
inspecting logs
using commands like kubectl logs to
inspect pods and services works okay but
trying to parse logs this way can be a
pain especially for beginners a tailored
logging interface is a more efficient
way to get the info you're looking for
debugging kubernetes with cli commands
is cumbersome
once again using a tool that's tailored
for kubernetes debugging can save you
from a lot of frustration
excessive time to build and deploy it's
always a best practice to improve
development velocity and not get stuck
in a lengthy build cycle on every change
to the code base
and finally it's a best practice to
share best practices if your team has
specific policies for developing
kubernetes apps those patterns should be
accessible as project templates that
your team can reuse to ensure conformity
and to make it easy for new devs to
onboard
so we're going to start implementing
these best practices with google's cloud
code cloud code is an ide plugin that
automates dev workflows for cloud native
applications you can see cloud code as
sort of a bridge between you developing
in your ide and google cloud it's
bringing the cloud to you
cloud code is particularly helpful when
developing with kubernetes because it
comes pre-installed with tools like
scaffold mini cube and the cloud sdk
scaffold is a command line tool that
handles the workflow for building
pushing and deploying your application
cloud code uses scaffold behind the
scenes so it acts as sort of a user
interface for the scaffold cli
minicube sets up a local kubernetes
cluster it's small but powerful and
extremely beginner friendly
cloud code is available for vs code and
jetbrains ides like intellij you can
also try out cloud code on google's
web-based ide the cloud shell editor all
of these tools cloud code cloud shell
scaffold and mini cube are a hundred
percent free to use and we encourage you
if you want to try it out right now go
ahead and install cloud code on your ide
or try it out in your web browser with
this link to the to an interactive
tutorial
so we've talked about best practices and
how it can be difficult to implement
them the question now is how do these
google cloud dev tools make it easy to
incorporate best practices into your
kubernetes development workflow
first you don't need to be a yaml expert
in order to write functional kubernetes
resource manifests
tools like cloud code that provide yaml
snippets and autocompletes make it so
that you can author entire kubernetes
manifest without looking at yaml
documentation
you should be developing on a cluster
that replicates your production cluster
as much as possible to avoid issues when
pushing to production you can configure
a mini cube cluster to quickly develop
and test locally with no added cost you
can also use scaffold to create distinct
profiles for dev versus prod and
incorporate customized and kept for even
more powerful deployment workflows
as mentioned before it's a good idea to
use a dedicated logging tool that makes
kubernetes logs more accessible with
cloud code's new logging support you can
drill down into your containers and
container builds and your deployment
logs and we'll you'll you'll see that in
a minute in the demo
for debugging sometimes prints and log
statements just aren't enough it's
useful to be able to step through the
code cloud code brings kubernetes
debugging into your ide it lets you do
step-by-step debugging live in your
kubernetes cluster locally and remotely
using the ide's debugging interface that
you're already familiar with
having an automated local dev loop is a
general best practice and you can set up
kubernetes iterative development using
scaffold scaffold has a file sync
functionality that prevents you from
needing to rebuild and redeploy your
containers on every little change
and finally you can use a tool like
cloud code custom samples to create
project templates or samples to easily
distribute your team's best practices
with custom samples you can have a
reusable kubernetes configured app that
your team can access right from their
ide
and now i'll hand things over to abby
for a demo
thanks kelsey let's get into intellij
and see some of these best practices in
action
to kick off this demo i'll show how you
can kubernetify a non-kubernetes
application with scaffold i already have
cloud code installed from the jet prints
marketplace which means scaffold has
been installed too since it's a managed
dependency i'll use scaffold's init
generate manifest command to get this
app working with kubernetes in seconds
and i want to mention that this
functionality will soon be added to
cloud code's ui you can view cloud code
as a front end for scaffold which is a
command line tool
and now scaffold's going to prompt me to
pick my builder and for my front end i
will be building with build packs and
for my back end i'll use the existing
docker file here scaffold looks at my
application and determines what the
kubernetes resources are and then it
creates a deployment.yaml file for each
one
and now that that's finished i have
manifest generated for my application
and a scaffold.yaml file that specifies
its build and deployment pipeline we'll
take a closer look at scaffold.yaml
later
this application is ready for kubernetes
but these manifests that were generated
are starting points you will likely want
to customize them your organization may
have certain naming patterns or file
system layouts in this case this
application needs some environment
variables and labels for the front end
and back-end containers
and an additional kubernetes resource to
deploy a mongodb service for our
database
i've added a version of this application
with these changes made to a custom
samples git repository cloud code's
custom samples feature allows your
organization to easily distribute best
practices by letting developers connect
their ides to custom sample repos which
i've already done here
a team best practice is to have starter
projects that are set up to fit your
team's preferred configurations when
talking in the context of cades
development this would include run
configurations and certain yaml files
and my new ready to go sample is called
next book so i'll create it
the next book application is a basic
kubernetes app with a front-end and
back-end service we've kept this demo
app simple to better demonstrate complex
kubernetes dev flows it includes logic
to read from and write to a database and
displays the most recently added
database entry let's take a look at the
contents of this project
this project is configured to use
scaffold for both development and
production workflows
that's all set up with this
scaffold.yaml file i've also set up run
configurations in my idea folder by
committing these files to your projects
repo this enables any developer to run
and develop your application the same
way this helps with onboarding in a team
environment
scaffold.yaml ties the container images
we're going to build to the k8 resources
we're going to deploy
scaffold supports a number of container
image builders like docker jib co and
more
i've already set up my scaffold file to
build my back end with a docker file and
my front end image with build packs
build packs are a set of opinionated
image builders that encode language
specific best practices for
containerizing applications
they save you from having to write
custom docker files
scaffold profiles are very powerful for
separating configurations for different
uses or environments including build
test and deployment configurations
i have two already set for development
and production which is a best practice
my dev profile applies development
settings which shouldn't be enabled in
production one of our new products
google cloud deploy leverages scaffold
profiles to gather configuration details
for each target environment
i'll dig deeper into the scaffold file
as i go through this demo
cloud code automatically installs
necessary tools like scaffold so we're
ready to start working on this
application
cloud code comes with a kubernetes
explorer
this gives you a view of all your
deployed k8's resources and is an
excellent tool for operators
looking closer at one of my existing
clusters i've deployed to i can explore
my deployed resources
and even shell into a running pod
to run some
commands cloud code supports any
conformant kubernetes cluster whether
that's a local cluster like minicube or
k3d or hosted by a cloud provider
today i'll be deploying this application
to my gke dev cluster
for this sample app my run
configurations are already defined so
that any developer can run this
application on intellij the same way i
would
i have two configurations
development and production
it's a best practice to tailor workflows
for different contexts
let's take a look at my development
configuration
this is a cloud code kubernetes
configuration that i've built on my
container register url is already set
and this is needed because my
scaffold.yaml doesn't specify an image
repository allowing developers to easily
deploy to multiple locations an example
of this is if you have a personal dev
repository and a production repository
my run configuration is set to run on my
gke dev cluster the option to
automatically rebuild and rerun turns on
scaffolds watch mode for iterative
development in the build deploy section
we already have a scaffold file so
nothing needs to be done here as a side
note though if you don't have a scaffold
file this is the spot where you'd be
prompted to initialize one with just a
couple clicks
one last thing i want to touch on before
running is that i have a deployment
profile set named dev
dev is one of my scaffold profiles that
i already defined in scaffold.yaml
looking at my scaffold diamond file
again my dev profile specifies a
dockerfile target
dev
for my backend docker file
now taking a look at my back end docker
file you'll see that it's multi-staged
with my dev target set running my
configuration will build the base image
along with the dev portion here
turning on my flask back ends debug mode
and if the target were set to prod
which is for my production run
configuration my flash debugger would be
turned off in production mode
now i'll focus on my dev cluster in the
kubernetes explorer and run this with my
development configuration
right now cloud code is building and
pushing my container images to my
cluster
now that that's done cloud code port
forwards my cluster services to my local
machine so all i have to do is click the
link for my front end you can also
explicitly set up port forwarding for
other resources like deployments or
stateful sets in scaffold.yaml now let's
take a look at this application and this
is my application running remotely on my
gke cluster
everything is looking as expected so
i'll enter a new entry to the database
and
yep my output box is displaying the
latest entry
deploying an app to a cluster generates
a ton of logs building container images
deployments spinning up pods and the log
streaming from your containers all
generate logs figuring out the best way
to view all these logs can require
running multiple coupe ctl commands
cloud code splits the logs up into
easily selectable sections this makes
finding where errors occurred in your
deployment process easy
logs are also streamed for each
container letting you focus on different
components of your application
so right now we're still running our
application and scaffolds watch mode is
waiting for us to make changes
now let's look at the yaml of our
deployed application and see if we can
make it better follow kubernetes best
practices
we don't have a readiness probe and you
should always have one so that
kubernetes knows when your app is ready
to serve traffic this gets us a step
closer towards zero downtime deployments
and higher availability
we're going to use cloud code's yaml
authoring support to create this probe
real quick
i'll go down to my container and press
control space
and there's the option for a readiness
probe
now to add some parameters i'll press
control space again
and pick tcp socket my port is 8080.
what other parameters do i need though
hovering over readiness probe shows me a
documentation and i see that i have a
couple more options
now i'll add initial delay seconds
set to 5 and period seconds set to 5.
that's looking good now i'll save this
file
scaffolds watch mode just kicked off and
we're redeploying
and now it's done
our readiness probe is ready
this whole rebuilding and redeploying
process is pretty fast but we can make
it faster and that is with file sync
by setting up scaffolds file sync
feature you can copy over a local file
that you've just edited with one in your
deployed container in seconds this
avoids the need to rebuild redeploy and
restart your corresponding pod on a file
change saving you local development time
to get filesync working with my
backend's docker file a little extra
configuration is needed but to save a
little time i've already done that
i'm using inferred syncing when using my
dev scaffold profile this means that
scaffold will look at my docker file to
determine the location of where my
edited files should be synced to all i
need to do is tell scaffold what files
to watch
i've added star.pi so that any python
file in my backend that i edit will
trigger a sync my friend automatically
has filesync turned on because it's
being built with build packs this auto
sync feature is specific to build packs
there are file type limitations when
using build packs but javascript is
supported so my front-end syncing is
good to go file sync may require
configuring your web framework to detect
and respond to file changes i'm using
flask's development mode to restart the
app on a dot pi change for compiled
languages or frameworks that don't
provide this support you'll need to use
an external file watcher like nodemon or
watch exec if you're building with build
packs watch exec is automatically
configured
now let's see if we can sync a backend
python file
to visually test this i'll hard code a
new entry into the output text box that
says this is syncing
now i'll open my run window back up and
save it
my logs are showing that a sync just
finished so let's check out my
kubernetes app now and give it a refresh
and there's that data i just set in
there with scaffolds file syncing
locally iterating on deployed kubernetes
application is super fast
now let's talk about debugging there are
a ton of ways to debug a kubernetes
application but what if debugging it was
as simple as debugging any application
in your ide
you should run and debug your
applications in environments that
closely mimic production so why not
remotely on a gke cluster
i could also switch to using a local
mini cube cluster to cut down latency
but since we're already talking about
gke clusters i'll stick with that so now
i'm going to try and debug my frontends
app.js file
and all i should need to do is place a
breakpoint i'll set it to trigger after
i post a message
and now i'll kick off debugging with
cloud code's debug mode
and once i've set my pads for my front
end and back-end containers
i can now open up my application and
post a message to see if we can trigger
this breakpoint
and there we go i'm now remotely
debugging my application on my gke
cluster right from my ide
i'll just step through the code a couple
times
and then finish running it
super simple
it's a good practice to add tests for
your container image and scaffold
supports running tests
for the last part of this demo i'm going
to run container structure tests with
scaffold container structure tests
validate the structure of your container
image
can check command outputs
and verify file content and metadata
here we have test files for the back end
and front end containers
these files are written in yaml but you
can also use json
in the back end i'm checking that python
is installed and that the requirements
file exists in the container in the
front end i'm testing to make sure i
don't have any comments that include xxx
left in my code because i definitely
don't want to push those into production
so my tests are written
now let's go over to scaffold.yaml
in my prod profile
i have configured scaffold to run the
container tests
now after scaffold builds the image
it'll run the tests before deploying to
the cluster
i'll switch to my production run
configuration and see if these tests
pass
looks like one of my tests didn't pass
let's take a closer look
so my backend container test passed
but it looks like my front end container
has a comment that's causing this to
fail i'll go fix that right now
i'll delete this comment here
and give it a run one more time
and everything passed this time this
application is now ready for production
thanks to google cloud's dev tools like
cloud code and scaffold
thanks for following along with us today
and if you want to check out the demo we
used you can find it on github
to try these tools out yourself and
maybe with your team install cloud code
from your ide's marketplace and finally
we encourage you to join the
conversation at cloud code slack channel
and on behalf of kelsey and i thank you
again and enjoy the rest of next